all right here's a video from
Tick Tock that went viral after a Libs
of tick tock posted it it's almost hard
to believe this is real but
it is real and these people still exist
in the world uh let's watch a little bit
of this
see it even if it is white feminism I
want to be able to go so I'm doing a
thing and if you live in the Pacific
Northwest you can do a thing with me
here's what it is next week which is
July 31st August 1st someday next week
on a weekday I am renting out a theater
in Northwest Portland the entire theater
the whole theater
the theater seats 46 people I think we
are only going to do 20 tickets so me
and 19 other people that's it in
addition to that there will be one
employee so the entire building the
entire Cinema is going to be one
employee plus 20 attendees that's it we
are the only people in the building and
every single person including that
employee is going to be wearing an n95
the entire time the employee is going to
put it on before they enter the building
they've been chosen specifically for
this purpose they seem to get it
um if you show up
because you bought a ticket I need to
see a kn-94 well fitted or a 95 well
fitted or p100 and if I see a bagging
mask I'm going to tell you to take it
off and put on one that I hand you I'm
holding onto a bunch of masks choose the
one you like best
um there are no concessions during the
movie they're not even going to open it
up do not bother bringing food or drinks
you may not take your mask off in the
movie if you need to scratch your nose
or you need to take a sip of water you
need to get up exit the theater do that
and then come back they're going to be
medically fragile people there this is
their first opportunity in like three
and a half years so we are not
around here folks
um no kids that can't wear a mask
solidly for two hours like I'm not gonna
do little kids because
I don't blame them but it is what it is
this is going to be a morning showing we
are the first people in the building so
we will be in and out well before
any other employees or other people well
I mean how can you turn down this
invitation this just sounds like a
thrilling time at the movie if you would
like to get up early in the morning
to go watch a two and a half hour movie
about Barbie
with a bunch of uh
lonely feminists who have not left their
homes or apparently showered in three
and a half years and if you would like
to be alone
in this haunted theater uh with all with
with these feminists
uh eating no snacks wearing a muzzle the
entire time
and required to leave the theater in
order to scratch your nose if you'd like
to do that then uh get in touch with
this woman I mean it's a little late
because I guess it's already happened so
unfortunately you missed out on that
opportunity but as she says
you know you could do the same thing
just sounds
like
actual hell it is what it's what hell
would be for me this is what Satan is
watching this and and uh and getting
getting all kinds of ideas I think
maybe Satan would actually be at the
theater you know you never know if
you're hiring you know that it's
incredibly hard to attract top talent
and with the current labor market
conditions even harder than ever that's
why you want to partner like the zip
recruiter who gets it zip recruiter
knows how tough it is right now but they
figured out solutions for the problems
you're facing try them for free at
ziprecruiter.com Wolf to reach more of
the right people zip recruiter post your
job to 100 plus job sites ziprecruiters
smart technology finds great matches for
your job and then lets you invite the
most qualified people to apply for your
job their price is really
straightforward you can stick to your
budget with no surprises team up with a
hiring partner like Zip recruiter who
understands what you need four to five
employers who post a zip recruiter get a
quality candidate within the first day
just go to this exclusive web address to
try ZipRecruiter for free
ziprecruiter.com Walsh again that's
ziprecruiter.com
w-a-l-s-h zip recruiter the smartest way
to hire
you watch that you know I watch that
and there was a part of me
actually I had to go to This Woman's
Tick Tock I had to Brave that I had to
make the perilous journey to her actual
Tick Tock account
because I it's a part of me is like
there's no this can't be real people
actually still living this way
everything about it this has to be a
parody
even the throwaway lines about even even
though it is white feminism it's like
you're you're you can't be a real person
this is AI this is not this this is a
joke
but what you realize is that no they're
this is real people really do live this
way
and probably more uh people live this
way than than we would like to think
um
in fact there was another tweet
yesterday with a similar theme from a
person who also appears to be real this
person tweeted relationship ending
argument with my partner of 17 years she
stopped wearing a mask today
let me make my own decisions and stop
trying to control me she said when I
gave her the facts about the virus I'm
not trying to control I'm trying to save
everyone in this house f everything
since someone who just
of course he he calls uh his I don't
know if it's his wife
but it's been with a woman for 17 years
and refers to her as my partner
um
and broke off this romantic
relationships with 17 years
because she's not still wearing a mask
three and a half years later
and presumably we're talking about in
the house so he's been wearing a mask
in his home like all the time for three
years
another thing that when you first see
that you think it was it's got to be a
parody there's no way how is this
possible
um but it is possible and these people
do exist because as we we talked about
all throughout covid
you know um
we learned a lot of things about human
nature and about our leaders that run
this country
and none of it was good
you know I'm afraid to say like we the
covet experience and the lockdowns and
everything that happened
it didn't teach us anything good about
human nature about people about this
country about our culture about Society
about our government all of it was quite
bad
um
but I think the the
kind of the underlying lesson
is that
for a lot of people
covid was the first time in their lives
that they had confronted their mortality
and it's not because covid posed for
them
this this grave risk that they weren't
already facing you know as we know for a
lot of people you already have obesity
that's more likely to kill you you drive
around your car every day and get a car
accident
but
just coveted and the way that it was
reported in the way that it was treated
all of that together
um the hype around covid
meant that for a lot of these people it
was just the first time that they'd even
thought about the fact that oh yeah you
know I can I can die
there I could actually die of something
they were mortal the whole time before
that they just never they really never
thought about it
and because in in the modern world
you're able to uh live this very
insulated life we don't talk about death
and we we we we keep death away from us
we Shield ourselves from it it's not
like the old days when you you know if
if you got to adulthood you would have
seen people die around you you're gonna
be around death you're aware of it right
uh you've got family members who are
buried like on your property and so
there's no way to avoid it but that's
not the way we live in modern society
we're very insulated from the reality of
death and so for a lot of these people
first time they'd ever even thought
about it and uh and it's
for a certain percentage of those people
it broke them
that confrontation with mortality broke
them and they they haven't recovered and
they never will
until they die which which they will and
it's not gonna be covered it'll be
something else because it was always
going to happen
so that's how you explain what you just
saw there thanks for checking out this
video if you'd like to listen to my full
podcast on the go you can check out the
Matt wall show on Apple podcast Spotify
or wherever you get your podcasts